Here's an illustration of
the workflow of intrusion detection
as well as the main components of
an intrusion detection system.
The input on an IDS is
data that describes
activities on systems and network.
The data is processed by the data
processor to extract activity records.
They are important for
security analysis this activity data
needs to be analyzed by
the detection engine.
The detection engine uses detection
models that have been already
constructed for the ideas that is
these models are stored with ideas.
If a detection rule determines
that there is an intrusion.
The IDS produces an alert.
The decision engine then
decides the appropriate action
according to decision table.
For example, this can be a response
that automatically blocks
a network connection or report that
is sent to the security admin.
Again, for the IDS to work properly,
we'll assume that system
activities are observable and are
captured in the input data to the ideas.
And when detection models are applied
to the activity data, normal and
intrusive activities
have distinct evidence.